so the official dark souls design works
books are incredible they have
interviews and concept art that give
wonderful insight into the development
process behind these games but the thing
i want to talk to you about today isn't
in the dark souls design works instead
it was specifically left out
archived on reset era are these
fantastic images allegedly drawn by an
artist named jokus wang first up there's
this dark hellscape where your eyes are
drawn towards a bleeding sun
there's art that looks like it might
have inspired cainhurst library from
bloodborne
there's this gothic courtyard which one
commenter points out merges the berlin
cathedral and the louvre there are these
statues that might once have been
graceful but have become horrifically
worn
but my personal favorite piece is this
sort of abandoned sewer area with just
enough light filtering through to
nourish gentle growths of moss i love
the verticality in this piece and i love
the way the artist uses light to draw
you in to every little nook it's
masterful now that first image should
have been familiar to anyone who saw the
dark souls 3 leaks that were published
all the way back in 2015 this famous
screenshot showed that same bleeding sun
and the world reduced to a hellish ruin
i remember those leaks were especially
shitty from software back then because
we know now that they were clearly
outdated at the time and misleading but
looking back now along with all this
artwork these things start to feel more
like lost treasures to me and i feel
like they do wonders for the intrigue
behind these games i'll of course take
this down if from software or jokus
request it but we get precious little
insight into the development process and
it's fun to imagine the game that could
have been of course if you want some
official insight into these games go and
buy the official design works books
they're well worth it if you can find
them for sale next number two it's no
secret that when you kill ornstein first
in dark souls 1 smoke grows larger and
when you kill smo first ornstein grows
larger or does he recently zully the
witch revealed this clever camera trick
that happens in this scene whereby
ornstein actually stays the same size
while smoe's body and the arena shrinks
instead considering there isn't a
functional size scaling value for
character models in the original dark
souls zully speculates that this camera
trick would have been far easier for
them to implement these secrets videos
have first and foremost become a way for
me to point you towards other creators
and their creations things that can
enrich your appreciation of the soul
series lately zoli the witch in
particular has been absolutely killing
it the youtube algorithm has finally
taken a liking to her short entertaining
videos and i noticed as well that it all
started with this one as you know if you
kill ornstein first you get super smoke
and if you kill smoke first you get
super ornstein but what happens if you
kill them both at exactly the same time
by using an aoe attack to force a tie
the winner is ornstein that's because
the next stage of the fight is actually
tied to whichever boss's death animation
ends first and smo has a faster death
animation but what happens if you kill
ornstein first and then smoke quickly
after to line up their animations
well you can't fromsoftware thought of
this and they added immortality to the
other character once their partner dies
interestingly if animation length is
removed as a factor with hacks and you
set both of their hp to zero then there
is code in the game that enables
ornstein as the winner in this scenario
every time
luckily this isn't possible in regular
gameplay because it also soft locks the
fight another thing i found fascinating
is how they work around boss health bar
issues in some fights in fights like the
four kings or the deacons there's
actually another member hidden off
screen and it's their health bar that
you see at the bottom of your screen and
they take damage on behalf of all of the
other members that you hit this also
goes for the gale boss fight where
second phase gail waits in this
structure in the distance when phase two
starts during the cutscene this damaged
second phase teleports down and the
fight continues from software tend to
remove a lot of cut content from their
games these days but this wolf snuck
through on a ps4 patch for dark souls 3.
it bears resemblance to the old wolf of
farin covenant model that you find in
this tower
down to having the same little bronze
bracelet
once it seems this model was planned to
be a part of the abysswatch's boss fight
here in a cutscene found by mkb123
and uploaded by drop off we see the wolf
appear as a part of the phase 2 revival
cutscene
here's a hot take i'm glad the wolf
wasn't added as a part of the fight i
think we have enough wolf fights in the
souls series don't you we've talked
before about how there are grabs that
you can escape in dark souls by pressing
r1 and l1 but for many years such a
thing was considered to be a glitch
turns out it has its own dedicated
systems in this video zully showcases
how grabs technically have their own hp
each escapable grab has 25 hp and each
press of r1 or l1 reduces that hp bar by
1. get it to 0 and your character
performs the escape throw animation
having the hp of the grab actually
visible makes your button mashing feel
so much more meaningful and i'm kind of
surprised that they didn't just add like
a sort of status meter for this in game
one reason they might not have added
that is because not every grab can be
escaped from in a recent demon souls
prepare to cry we talked about
boletaria's proclivity for slaves and
how important they were to their wars
and to their greater society
turns out slaves are more entrenched in
this game than i thought
as you head up to fight alant the final
boss take a look through the walls of
the elevator hidden within the mechanism
are two slave soldiers working
tirelessly to bring visitors up to their
master
next sticking with demon souls everyone
knows that the manta rays detach from
the storm king to start attacking you
but did you know that the projectiles
that the storm king shoots are also
small manta rays i guess blue point
wanted to give you an excuse to use that
awesome photo mode recently a fantastic
article that you should read was posted
to the playstation blog which details
the process behind capturing the
incredible animations of the demon souls
remake and when you see these actual
people hefting around these heavy props
to mimic the weight of the weapons
in-game you really do appreciate the
effort that went into this because the
tough thing to get right about this
remake was that the cadence of
animations and movement wasn't supposed
to be changed much from the original but
they did want to update the animations
themselves and they updated every single
one of them one of the performers says
performed too quickly the movements
would lack clear arcs and silhouettes
performed too slowly they might lose
their weight and inertia and they said
that they had to focus really hard on
where an animation starts and ends as
well the article is a great read it
explains how and why this project was so
difficult even for people with over 20
years of motion capture experience
the most striking animations in the
remake are the brutal and complex
reposts and backstabs all of which have
different animations depending on the
weapon you're using and also how many
hands you're carrying it with this game
is a technical marvel and a big part of
me wishes that from software had a bit
of that blue point polish within them
don't get me wrong from software's
current game development cycle is
incredible it's super efficient and they
pump out quality games with quality
gameplay way faster than most studios
but with elton ring looking a lot like
dark souls 3 the game appearance is
starting to age a little you have to
admit that and i wonder when we might
see a sort of visual leap forward from
them not saying it has to happen now but
sooner or later you have to admit
something is going to give moving on to
sakura we've talked about the gyobu skip
before and even the blazing bull skip
after that but what if you performed
these glitches during the gauntlets of
strength one twitter user did just that
and shared it with me revealing this
world that renders in in a strange way
you should try it and see what oddities
you can find but the best place to visit
by far seems to be the silver grass
field which shows a lightning storm
during the day with surreal reflections
and lighting number eleven we've all
seen or heard the sentries in sakura who
hammer a metal pan with a metal rod but
did you know they can actually attack
you since they die in one hit and they
usually stand apart from other enemies
not many people would notice this but
stand in melee range and parry them and
you'll even be able to perform a fairly
unique riposte animation to kill them i
learned about this from ongbal a sakura
master who uploads these stunning clips
of him flawlessly killing bosses in this
game not only are there no errors in
these clips but he weaves together
interesting combos with prosthetic
weapons and jumps which leads to some
incredible takedowns for someone like me
who really appreciates secular's combat
more than any other souls game they are
well worth a sub now sakura's combat is
good and all but
this is gameplay poison rolling
researched by limit breakers a few
months ago we learned that the hunter's
role inherits the effects of the poison
gems that are attached to your right
hand weapon so poison comes in two
flavors in this game there's slow poison
which builds up and then drains enemy hp
over time and there's rapid poison which
builds up and deals damage all at once
relative to slow poison rapid poison is
a way better option and it can even be
used against some bosses that have
really large hp pulls to good effect but
relative to you know actually hitting
the enemy with your weapon or actually
using good gems no poison and rolling
with it isn't that great you can use the
hunter's bone to speed up the process
but many bosses have 999 poison
resistance anyway so it kind of makes it
a pointless endeavor unless you're yumfa
and then it is good for entertaining
challenge runs so make sure you go and
check that out as well you'll learn even
more secrets from their videos like this
one
so limit breakers also put out another
video recently that shows off the bow
bash of demon souls which is something
that hasn't really been showcased on
youtube before it has a really strange
input it requires you to face away from
your opponent and then snap in the
opposite direction while pressing r2
damage is modified by whichever bow you
use and how upgraded that weapon is but
i'll leave it to limit to teach you the
specifics one of the best things about
the remake is that all of this jank was
left in this super modern ps5 title
moving back to bloodborne there were
some things in this game that i never
thought we'd see and vika amelia's face
before she transforms was one of them
her side profile definitely gives you
this
younger and prettier impression to my
imagination anyway
but the reality is
yeah bloodborne has been explored a ton
in recent years thanks to the new tools
that it has and talented modders like
lance mcdonald though perhaps some
things are better left unseen lance also
has a video showing off a never before
seen cutscene from the wet nurse boss so
go and check that out on his channel
last the fantastic video idea is
illusory wall who got ai to generate a
real-life cast of dark souls based on
their in-game models some of this stuff
is absolutely stunning some of it is
absolutely horrifying but all of it kind
of makes me want a film based on these
games for the first time i mean it'd be
a nightmare trying to write a movie
script for the soul series but as
illusory wall notes in the video a lot
of these faces already bear resemblance
to real life actors and here's one last
crazy secret your middle mouse button
can be used to open links in new tabs
and that's exactly what you should do
for every link in the description
including the one for soul arts the
campaign is literally about to end maybe
like a day left now so become a backer
if you want to join us on this journey
to produce something really special
thank you for watching hopefully we get
some elden ring news soon
and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]